there are two things I think you all on
pitron might be interested in okay uh
one is our subba that we ended up making
because we tried everything
else
um I think why everything else appears
to work is nobody's doing aosi
correctly when you're doing Oshi
correctly that means you are pinning uh
UK Center for a follow-up
attack it is a difficult ukemi to
take and if you get it wrong and you
will as you're learning it it'll break
your hands
okay most people require their hands to
be broken a little bit because they will
always try to muscle against the ukemi
take it in the shoulders and you can
just watch all throughout chiba's
lineage everyone's taking it in the
shoulders um and not actually doing ukmi
when I was in Cha's dojo we used to wear
or I didn't like the idea but everyone
was wearing hockey mitts because cha
Sensei would bust the hell out of your
hands um and I moved away from it
because it still hurt he he was still
powerful enough it's still
hurt um and I was so slow and cumbersome
in the Joe transitions for example
because you're wearing these hockey
mitts that hockey players just hold the
stick one or two ways it's not all the
different hand transitions that you have
in the Joe so I had to you know in my
mind Hey I should be able to reconcile
the young energy um and you'll see me to
this date I I'll even have my dasi go
hard and I still I don't wear a subba at
all you're still not going to break my
hands okay but to get there it sure
helps if you have some cushion for when
you mess it up and that's why we were
interested in subba not hockey mitts
they're too slow in
transitioning and we've tried everything
and you can move close camera okay uh
and they're usually very expensive so
here is I don't remember where we got
this might be king fisher I'm not
knocking king fisher I love king
fisher um they're boken uh they're subi
toll I can't recommend them enough
they're just absolutely beautiful and
super well balanced uh but this is one
of theirs and they just rolled thick
leather and what happens is it gets
continually hit and leather stretches so
it would stretch and it would just keep
sliding down the Suka and eventually
it's doing nothing for
you we tried the cheap plastic ones that
come with your cheap bokan when you buy
them but we just break them they just
got hit so hard that uh the brittleness
of it would
shatter we had another company that
tried to make it again I'm not sure who
makes this anymore uh but it was the
same it's
leather and um we tried to design one
too out of
leather um we had
a a um Rancher that I used to train with
and he had access to bullhide and we
were like we're going to make one that
works but the problem with leather is
under the impact it keeps getting
stretched by the Suka because the Suka
is wider so it eventually
fails we tried the urethane wands and
they're even more br ridle than the
plastic ones they just snap immediately
okay so what we've come up with is these
rubber ones okay there's some downside
to them because they kind of Bounce the
the wood does bounce off of them but
when you are trying to learn the
Uki you're going to be trying to absorb
it anyways and so that bounce is not as
pronounced as you think
um you also cannot rely on the bouncing
of the nagz bulen or Joe because it's
going to go over the top and hit your
forearms nonetheless it hurts you're
going to start yielding to it and you
don't have a bouncing problem like you
might think but this is our highest
protection and it looks like this on a
book
in okay and you see most of our people
are sticking with that and I don't have
a problem with
that and the next is a little smaller
just I just need a little safety cushion
in case Sensei you're are pissed okay
and so it's a little smaller and gets
you to like a little training wheel and
it looks like this on the bookking and
to be honest it's not going to save you
at all all but maybe you're you won't
break anything if we're going full speed
that that's kind of what it does but
it's going to hurt like mfer if you
can't take the ukami okay and all you do
is you just shove it down any size book
in that you want it it rubber flexes so
it'll work okay and then there's enough
friction on there it does however Mark
some uh bulk in because rubber running
on it you push it back so sometimes some
people will use the subad to help with
that okay and you can buy those anywhere
any Marshal any Amazon has them even
cheap Century martial arts sells a subba
Don so you might be interested in these
training subas if you really want to
learn safely how to do makot to kot
uh Etc and how to learn the ukemi for
them okay
sub the next thing I mention again is
because no one else was making them we
started to make them uh James here he's
a mechanical engineer and he knows how
to do all this stuff he I can do that
easy and he does it's probably not easy
he's just a humble guy okay um and we
base them on the knives that that you
know are quite commonly understood as
fighting knives or even that I carry so
here you have a corit
design um the cambic knife is good to
know because it's a halfway between a
cutting and a grappling tool so you can
grapple much better with this thing um
and
my
um sometimes my everyday carry is is a
corent on patrol it's always a Coran
bent it's one of my blades that I carry
on my support side is a camit so we do a
lot of camit and a lot of people here
like the camit and so they just rock
that one in our knife
training the other one is this classic
uh dagger uh from World War II fam
famous britz invented this design um and
it allows us to go ahead and do double
edge um knife training because the
wooden Tonto does someone have that
wooden Tonto can you grab
it um is only a blade on one side and
sometimes we want to take advantage of a
double-sided blade okay and so we go
ahead and use this stabbing tool also
there's more geared towards
stabbing uh one thing you'll notice is
these these Tanto that everyone Buy
um they just don't feel like knives they
just feel like a big pole in my hand
they act like a big pole in my hand uh
whereas this one this will feel like a
knife to you um a lot of times if you're
rocking the silver one it'll feel like a
knife to UK at too okay and they don't
want you touching them with that and uh
it's safe to a point no pun intended but
there's no cutting Ed Edge on it you can
see that it's thick enough and there's
no Cutting Edge here either but I will
admit that I missed a a disarm on
Tristan who came in like a mad man on me
and you could you could see the remnant
of that so this is much better but it it
punched just a little bit um still
that's just because of how hard he hit
me with it um it's not going to kill you
though okay and this is follows the same
P the same width and everything and the
same no Edge okay but it's real enough
that everyone's going to pay attention
and train very mindfully okay um It's
Made of aluminum right I think so yeah
aluminum okay and then he does some
designs I don't know if he's going to
open it up but he put our Crest on there
that we have and these are the diamonds
that represent
shuidi uh and the reconciliation of the
two mines
okay uh I don't know if he will if he's
going to open the the patterns like a
different paracord I don't know um but
if you're interested and you're like oh
I want this color so this is OD green
and this one's black okay maybe he has
the the ability to do that I don't
really handle the store of the dojo um I
don't get anything from what James makes
I don't even know what James sells them
for or how much money I could look into
it and James is all driving a Ferrari
down the street I don't know okay so I'm
I'm sorry I don't know um but what I
will try to do is get people on patreon
some
discount um that we can give you so you
can start more more uh maybe more okay
with spending some money on on this kind
of stuff Stu as and moving away from
this kind of stuff
okay all right thank you